christopher ruffa who's done a great job
exposing critical race theory in schools
is over at the manhattan institute
chris ruffo has just come upon
some private footage of an all hands
call at disney a video call where the
disney corporate president
described her multiple trans and
pansexual children and called for more
lgbtq leads in disney movies
i'm here as a mother of two queer
children actually
um
uh one transgender child um
[Music]
and one pansexual child um
and and also as a leader
um and that was the thing that really
got me because i have heard so much from
so many of my colleagues over the course
of the last couple weeks
um in open forums and through emails and
phone conversations and
um i feel a responsibility to speak um
not just for myself but for them
um to all of us we had a we had an open
forum last week at 20th where
um
again the home of really incredible
groundbreaking
lgbtqia stories over the years where
um one of our execs stood up and said
you know we only have a handful of queer
leads
in our content and i went what
that can't be true and i and i and i
realized oh it actually is true we have
many many many lgbtqia characters
in our stories and
and and yet we don't have enough
leads
an issue a sexual and ideological issue
that affects
an extraordinarily small percentage of
the population that is represented in an
extraordinary large proportion of the
media and in the classrooms and in the
corporate boardrooms the problem we are
told is that
it's not represented enough
trans visibility day where do we need
transvisibility day
the issue is visible folks the issue is
visible i the elites in every sphere of
our society are pushing it they're
shouting it from the rooftops
the corporate president of disney
says that it's very important that we
have not just more lgbt lmnop characters
in our movies there are already a lot
but we need more lgbt lmnop
leads
there are actually already a lot but we
need more and she says this because
she's the parent she's the mother
of
a transsexual child
and a pansexual child
now
she's not she is not the mother of a
transsexual and a pansexual
she i'm sure is the mother of these two
children
and i have no doubt that these children
are confused i don't i don't doubt her
that they have sexual confusion but she
is not the mother of a transsexual and a
pansexual because those are not real
categories of being
i'm not denying anybody's existence
i'm not saying that anyone is invisible
to use the language that is so popular
these days on the left
but the people that we're talking about
here are not transsexual or pansexual as
the newest i don't know what i think
pansexual is just a high-class version
of bisexual i don't exactly know what
what even the meaning the purported
meaning of pansexual is but whatever it
is
these people are not that because it's
not a real category of being because a
man cannot secretly be a woman it's just
not possible lump that one away with
bigfoot and the boogeyman it's not real
the
confusion that these people have may be
real a psychological problem
that they have might be real or a social
problem which seems to be the case as
these minor minor
relatively
small issues in terms of the population
have now exploded to a huge proportion
of gen z in particular so it might be
the social problem might be real the
confusion might be real but the actual
condition
is not because it's it is not possible
i i
i repeat it because we seem to be so
confused it is not possible for a man to
secretly be a woman or for a man to
become a woman
or for a man to change his it is not
sometimes the left will tell you well
michael sex and gender are different sex
is not gender and they say that and they
have a lot of confidence when they say
that but it doesn't mean anything it's
not true they they simply declare it but
they don't provide any evidence for that
what they seem to be insinuating is that
sex is physical and gender is
metaphysical but then you have to probe
that question further you say okay well
where is gender gender is not in the
brain it's not in the body it's not in
the genitals it's not in the chromosomes
so what is gender it's non-physical okay
would seem that you're talking about the
soul right you're talking about the
human soul
and very often at that point they'll say
no absolutely not the soul is not real
we're just talking i'm talking about the
brain okay well if you're talking about
the brain then you're saying it's
physical so now you're saying that sex
and gender are physical and yet your
your physicality can be both male
entirely male and entirely female that's
not possible that violates the law of
non-contradiction we've known that since
old uncle aristotle
well even if they go and say okay gender
is non-physics let's say they'll say
that uh gender is socially constructed
okay if it's socially constructed then
reconstruct it if it's causing you this
great deal of suffering and one of them
is immutable your body your physique and
then the other one is changeable your
your
socially constructed gender identity
then just reconstruct it that's pretty
easy problem solved why would you
undergo painful
destructive surgeries and hormone
therapies when you could just change the
social construction well no because it's
back in the body okay then we're back to
square one it's an incoherent ideology
that benefits absolutely no one and is
driving society crazy because a bunch of
elites can't work through their own
personal problems and because a bunch of
elites are enthralled to an
extraordinarily stupid and destructive
ideology
it's not just this woman it's not just
this lady
who's who what are the odds has two
trans and pansexual children the the
odds of having one
even according to the most generous
statistics are infinitesimally small the
odds of having two maybe
maybe there's something more going on
either there is something in the water
and alex jones is right or
maybe there's something more going on
socially maybe there's something more
going on within the family maybe there's
something going on ideologically a
disney production manager
was also caught on this open call
uh
claiming that we need more lgbt
lmnop representation all over the place
in disney
i've had the privilege of working with
the moon girl team for the last two
years
and they've been really open to
exploring queer stories and part of i'm
on the production side uh part of uh the
work that i feel like i can put in is um
making sure that we take place in modern
day new york so making sure that that's
like an accurate reflection of new york
so i put together like a tracker of our
background characters to make sure that
we have like the full breadth of
expression and uh we got into a very
similar conversation carrie of like oh
all of our like gender non-conforming
characters are in the background and so
it's not just a numbers game um
of how many lgbtq plus characters you
have
we got
the further uh the the more centered a
story is on a character the more nuanced
you get to get into their story and
especially with like trans characters
you can't see if someone is trans
there's not one way to look trans and so
kind of the only way to have these like
canonical trans characters canonical
asexual characters canonical bisexual
characters is to give them stories where
they can like be their whole selves
canonical
transsexual care not we don't just need
the characters we mean canonical
transsexual and canonical asexual
characters
where they can be themselves that's the
funniest part of all that's the funniest
part of all because the transgender
ideology explicitly says as that
commenter made clear at the top it
explicitly says don't be yourself
be
an imaginary version of yourself
be
a fantasy
be the way that you
would prefer that you're yourself to be
rather than the way that you are in
reality it's the opposite of living
authentically it's the opposite of
living your true life even asexuality
man is a sexual being
sex is very important to human nature as
we all know that's why we're debating
sex so much in our politics
we need more of these characters it made
me think disney is just over disney's
just completely over i like disney i was
never a crazy disney kid i never i
didn't watch the disney channel i wasn't
gaga over the movies but i liked them in
particular i liked pinocchio i liked
the lion king i liked the movies i
watched them as a kid i liked the older
ones snow white
and those movies really were great
and i don't just want to sound like an
old fuddy-duddy man saying everything's
worse these days but it is worse if
you're now taking
really important aspects of human nature
the love between a man and a woman at
the center of the sort of of the human
world at the center of society if you
take that away if you if you deny sex
and sexual reality if you deny
the things that motivate people and
instead you superimpose political
correctness on top of it which is a
denial of reality ultimately it's a
denial of reality well then the movies
are not going to be as good and we know
that the movies aren't as good i'm not
saying disney only makes total crap
these days but the movies that disney is
making today
are worse than the movies that disney
made 30 years ago and they're worse than
the movies that disney made 60 and 70
years ago
so we've still got the old movies
if you have them on dvd or something
good for you download them now save them
because disney is over you can't
you can't
in good conscience expose your kids to
this crap not even because it's going to
completely ruin their lives although if
they're peddling transgenderism it it
won't help but just because they're
they're just not good movies they're not
going to be edifying if the stories
they're telling are contrary to human
nature and contrary to reality and these
are the lunatics who are running disney
now these people who think that the most
important thing to do in children's
programming is pedal far left
sexual ideologies before we close out
disney we've got the executive producer
latoya ravenous talking about how it's
so important in disney one thing that
she has really taken up is queering
that's a verb i guess
everything
our leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so like i i feel
like
i felt like it was i mean like maybe it
was that way in the past but i guess
like something must have happened in the
last like like they are turning it
around they're going hard and then
all that like momentum that i felt like
that
sense of i don't have to be afraid to
like
let's have these two characters kiss
let's in the background like i was just
wherever i could just basically adding
queerness to like if you see anything
queer in the show i'm proud of them but
like i just was like no one would stop
me and no one was trying to stop
everywhere it's everywhere at the the
senate candidate republican senate
candidate blake masters he tweeted out
the other day in response to one of
these crazy issues he said
not everything has to be gay
we're not saying we're not saying
nothing but not
not everything not every single thing
why is this even coming up
because florida passed a law
saying that kindergarten teachers
kindergarten through third grade
teachers
can't preach
transgenderism
and sex in the classroom
this should have been common sense you
shouldn't need a law for that that
should be so obvious
and in response to disney a children's
entertainment company said no that's too
far
if we can't teach transgenderism to kids
if we can't queer everything if we can't
groom little kids let's call it what it
is
then we're going to fight back we're
going to fight back in florida around
the country it is unconscionable
to give your money to disney at this
point we need to figure out
an alternative
did you like that clip hold on
whether you did or you didn't i don't
really care subscribe anyway ring that
bell get the notifications head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe
leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]